alors vos premières réactions le veut je
vous ramène à hier soit quand vous avez
entendu parler de ça sur votre téléphone
j'imagine première réaction bienvenus ma
première réaction a été une réaction de
joie évidemment pour les 2 maicon mais
deux furies l'endroit de la chine parce
qu'on démontrait instantanément
ce que la chine y est depuis toujours
c'est-à-dire que les deux michael avait
été arrêtée strictement en représailles
contre l'arrestation de bananes mangues
et que c'était un dossier donc de ce
qu'on appelle le diplomatie des otages
alors la chine qui se prétend une grande
puissance qui parle de la grande
coopération internationale
elle confirmait dans ce geste là en
laissant aller les 2 maicon que les 2
maicon avait été là pendant plus de
mille jours comme vous dites que pour
une affaire d'otages dans 1/2 mésentente
avec les états unis et le canada qu'est
ce que ça vous dit sur le poids qu'a dû
mettre un job hayden et les américains
le fait qu'on a effectivement libérée en
même temps on présume que les américains
ont dit on voit on va laisser à l'émail
ouaddou mais on veut les 2 maicon dans
un avion à la même heure
comment vous interprétez
qu'ils ont dû forcer à faire
il ya un problème majeur de relations
entre la chine et les etats unis c'est
ça qui est important aux yeux des choix
et probablement qu'effectivement il ya
une ya eu un poids énorme qui a été
exercée par l'administration américaine
pour que cette histoire se résolve à
l'avantagé des deux parties et pour les
américains ce qui était important c'est
que x ou y reconnaissez dans ce que
madame membres a fait au nom de la
compagnie mais il ya une chose qu'il
faut dire patrice dans tout ça et le
parler du rôle extrêmement important de
dominic barton l'ambassadeur canadien
pékin monsieur barton au printemps a
passé trois semaines à washington avec
sa collègue l'ambassadrice du canada à
washington à négocier avec
l'administration américaine avec la
maison blanche dès que monsieur monsieur
by donne est arrivé au pouvoir il ya eu
2 nouvelles discussions qui ont commencé
à travers barak n'a été mêlé à ça vous
connaissez la réputation monsieur walton
est probablement un des des personnages
dans le monde des affaires avant qu'il
entre en diplomatie qui avait le plus
grand réseau de contacts dans le monde
auprès des chefs le gouvernement chef
d'état son rôle a été extrêmement
important discret mais important les
chinois savait qu'ils jouaient un rôle
dans cette négociation l'aïe était pas
question pour monsieur barton que tout
ça se règle sans qu'il n'y ait une
garantie de libération pour les 2 maicon
moi ce qui m'a étonné et c'est parce que
je disais ça au début si à laquelle je
pensais personnellement je savais que ça
s'en venait vous savez il y avait
beaucoup de choses qui avait été dit et
on savait que ça s'en venait mais je me
disais les chinois vont attendre
quelques temps avant de libérer les deux
mike cohen aloro pour continuer ce mythe
de des accusations d'espionnage est tout
sauf faire un échange en fait entre
guillemets de prisonniers mais le fait
qu'ils aient été libérés immédiatement
qui soit arrivé au canada avec
l'ambassadeur byetone dans l'avion dans
le le jet privé ça confirme que les
chinois n'avaient cette valeur là en
main que pour négocier la libération de
madame angles et si c'est cette pratique
là devait continuer de la part d'un état
encore une fois qui se prétend une
grande puissance qui valait bientôt la
première puissance mondiale c'est
extrêmement dangereux c'est extrêmement
dangereux parce qu'on ne peut pas entre
pays responsable
utiliser des moyens comme ça pour régler
les différends et sam pour moi c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus fondamental dans ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui malheureusement les
deux michael ont souffert terriblement
pour qu'on découvre en fait qu'ils
avaient été pris simplement en otage
dans une affaire commerciale et
judiciaire et comment doit-on voir
l'avenir de tous ces québécois ces
canadiens qui font des affaires en chine
parce que c'est un partenaire commercial
important qu'est ce que ça vous dit sur
l'avenir des relations la baisse encore
une fois
je pense qu'il va falloir poser de
sérieuses questions aux chinois
le fait qu'ils aient admis en fait cette
fois ci dans faisons cet étang cet
échange là qu'il y avait une
négociation par voie d'otages c'est
énorme si on laisse sans conséquence à
mon avis ça risque de continuer en chine
et dans d'autres pays parce que les
chinois on n'a pas cette impression là
peut-être quand on regarde la chine de
l'extérieur mais la chine est très
écouté dans le monde
j'arrive de d'égypte où la chine étant
un modèle en egypte l'egypte est en
train de se développer à une vitesse
absolument folle sur le modèle chinois
donc si les chinois se permettent
d'avouer même publiquement qu'ils ont
enlevé ces deux personnes là simplement
pour mettre la pression sur pour la
libération de ma maman imaginez tous les
dangers qui vont surgir partout dans le
monde vous êtes peut-être trop jeune ou
le public se souvient peut-être pas de
l'époque ou au liban par exemple les
américains les français tout le monde
était présent au liban il y avait des
enlèvements d'otages parce que tous les
jours les groupes terroristes libanais
négocié par voie d'enlèvement d'otages
ont dit c'est une époque révolue mais
non c'est ce qui est arrivé avec les 2
maicon et c'est extrêmement grave de la
part du grand pouvoir chiens est-ce que
par ailleurs le fait que byden dû
négocier phares on le voit le résultat
le monde les canadiens sont arrivés au
même moment à ce que ça vous dit pas que
buydens peu un peu faire contrepoids
recaler les états unis faire un peu
contrepoids et que les chinois il ya
quand même une limite qui peuvent pas
dépasser ou bien où dans votre esprit il
n'y en a plus beaucoup de limites dans
leur esprit m non je pense que l'échelon
avait absolument besoin d'eux et ont
besoin de réduire les différends avec
quand même la première puissance
mondiale les états unis cette affaire là
embêtait tout le monde et c'est pour ça
que la chine a accepté que des
négociations se
semaine dans le sens qui est arrivé qui
a été conclu hier c'est à dire qui est
vraiment parce que c'est pas une
j'entendais votre invité un peu plus tôt
qu'il disait en chine vous savez les
chinois savent qu'ils avaient savais
qu'il y avait deux otages canadiens
savaient qu'ils étaient accusés de
l'espionnage et de trahison et dans le
stade aussi et j'en étais interpellé
dans la rue sur ce conflit la somme à la
mangue et sur les deux otages canadiens
mais vous le voyez aujourd'hui la chine
parle très peu de la libération des deux
canadiens parce que les chinois ne sont
pas fiers de ça c'est une concession
difficile qui ont dû faire et en même
temps c'est une concession qui illustre
comme je vous ai dit cette situation
tellement invraisemblable qu'on ait
utilisé des étages pour négocier un
règlement diplomatique avec les états
unis alors donc c'est une situation qui
les choix sont pas fiers de ça donc il
ya eu des concessions de chaque côté on
dit je comprends pas tellement le
règlement à l'américaine parce que
huawei en fait ne sera pas finalement
condamné mais les états unis avaient
besoin de la reconnaissance de la part
de roi ou et des erreurs commises
s'était fait semble-t-il en cours hier -
pour pouvoir adresse a probablement et
posé d'autres mesures oui c'est une
petite tape sur les doigts mais pas
d'accusation donc il ya comme un une
sortie crise là mais j'ai besoin janvier
à ce que vous faisiez là-bas en chaîne
qui vous le connaissez bien la chaîne
vous aimez lâcher les est ce que des
gens d'affaires vous disais nous on
commence à sérieusement avoir peur on a
plus envie cette chaîne là se durcit
politiquement et on sait pas jusqu'où ça
ira tout à fait c'est de plus en plus de
gens ont peur de venir en chine moi
j'essaie quand même de convaincre les
gens que si on ne fait pas
d'erreur sur le plan de la justice si on
fait des affaires honnêtement et de
façon transparente il ya encore une
certaine sécurité
en chine mais au moment où je vous dis
ça et je dis ça au public canadien
québécois
je me dis c'est invraisemblable ce qu'on
vient d'apprendre les chinois
reconnaissent eux mêmes cela alors ça
peut ça pue je voulais dit ça peut être
l'exemple qui sera suivie dans d'autres
pays et je peux vous dire qu'au moment
où l'on se parle je connais par exemple
un homme d'affaires québécois qui est
pris en chine dans un différend
judiciaire il ne peut pas sortir du pays
il est donc entre guillemets prisonniers
à l'intérieur de la chine et même
l'ambassade même les diplomates
canadiens ne peuvent pas toucher à ça
tellement c'est délicat il ya des choses
comme ça qui se pensent
donc dans quel contexte pourquoi on ne
peut pas toucher à ça c'est que le
contexte où tout tout ce différend
commercial c'est ces produits n'est pas
clair et c'est le problème à la fois
c'est ce que je vous disais c'est le
problème à la fois de l'homme d'affaires
canadien et deux
ethnies de ses
ex partenaires chinois mais quand on est
droit en affaires en principe on ne
devrait pas avoir ce problème là sauf
que les deux maillots étaient des gens
droits en affaires qui faisait chacun
leur métier de façon ouverte et honnête
puis regardez ce qu'ils auraient